CLARIDA: Well, good morning, everyone.
I'm Richard Clarida.
And I'll be moderating this session with John
Williams.
This meeting is part of the C. Peter McColough
Series on International Economics.
And so we'll be pursuing the following format.
We'll begin with about 25 minutes or so of
a Q&A session up here.
And then the remaining 30 minutes will be
question and answer time for the audience.
Well, when I got the request a couple of weeks
ago to moderate this session I accepted immediately.
I, myself, have been looking forward to it.
Just a brief introduction of our speaker,
and then we'll go right into the Q&A.
John Williams is the president of the San
Francisco Federal Reserve District Bank, and
has been president since 2011.
Before that, he was the director of research
at the San Francisco Fed and really, under
his leadership, turned into one of the very
top research groups in the Fed system.
He began his career years ago at the Federal
Reserve Board and was part of the group there
bringing the Fed's modeling efforts into the
21st century.
And many of us now actually use the Fed models
because they're now made available to the
public.
And John had a big hand in developing that,
has a Ph.D. in economics from Stanford and
studied also at LSE and UC Berkeley.
So let's get right into the opening set of
questions before we turn it over to the audience.
So, John, what is your outlook for the U.S.
economy-unemployment, inflation, and growth?
And if that materializes, how many rate hikes
do you think you would be recommending?
WILLIAMS: So I think 2016's going to look
a lot like 2015 in many ways.
I expect GDP growth to be about 2 percent-real
GDP growth this year, like we had last year.
I think it's basically the same set of issues,
strong domestic growth especially in the service
sector, some subtraction from growth because
of the strong dollar and weakness abroad.
So basically this balancing of the domestic
economy kind of doing well, but being-facing
some headwinds from abroad.
I expect to see pretty solid growth this year,
like we saw last year, over 2 million jobs
this year and I expect the unemployment rate
to continue to edge down from 5 percent today,
down a few more tenths.
My own view is that we're basically at full
employment or very near it based on 5 percent
employment rates.
And I feel that's very good news.
And with a strong economy and with the dollar
and oil prices and other influences basically
turning more neutral in terms of inflation,
I view inflation as moving back gradually
over the next year or two to our two percent
goal.
Like you said, I started this job in March
of 2011.
It's been a long slog, but actually I think,
you know, on our full-employment mandate we're
basically there.
And on our inflation mandate, I do think that
we not only made good progress but I'm pretty
optimistic that we'll get to our goal in the
next year or two.
CLARIDA: And then if that-if that outlook
materializes, what rate hikes would you be
recommending?
WILLIAMS: Oh, I didn't get away with skipping
the rate question?
CLARIDA: (Laughs.)
WILLIAMS: Oh, OK.
So, you know, I think that our basic strategy
is the right one.
And that's, you know, slowly or gradually
removing accommodation, meaning raising interest
rates over the next few years, and getting
our interest rates back to normal.
Now, the exact timing of when we have the
next rate increase will depend on the data,
depend on how we're doing relative to our
goals.
But when I look back at the March economic
projections that my colleagues and I put out
suggesting, you know, over the rest of the
year, say, two or maybe three rate increases
this year, maybe one or two more next year,
so three or four next year, I think that's
still about right.
It will depend on the data.
We're still getting another month's of data
before the next-for the June meeting.
I want to analyze that and come to a conclusion.
Obviously we'll be meeting numerous times
a year, get to keep doing that, and think
about it.
CLARIDA: Thank you.
One of the bright spots in the economy recently
has been the pickup in wages.
Not only are wages rising, but labor share
of national income has been rising.
So how does the Fed factor that into its reaction
function for the economy?
WILLIAMS: Sure.
And, you know, the wages has actually been
the puzzling part of the story.
You know, wage growth has not picked-we kind
of would expect with unemployment coming down
to about 5 percent, wage growth would have
started picking up earlier.
I think a number of factors have held wages
down.
One is the very slow productivity growth and
some other factors.
But we are seeing some signs-encouraging signs
that wages are starting to pick up.
I think, you know, wages are the biggest cost
for businesses.
So that's going to put somewhat upward pressure
on inflation.
I think we have to be realistic, kind of what's
the normal for wage growth.
My own view is productivity growth probably
will average about 1 1/2 percent over the
next several years.
So, you know, we might be seeing wage growth
of something like 3, 3 1/2 percent of normal.
So we're moving towards that.
And I think that's a positive sign.
It shows, I think, a couple things: One is,
you know, that we are close to or at full
employment, with wage growth picking up that's
kind of a sign of where the labor market is.
Obviously, it also is a sign that, you know,
we're seeing some uplift to inflation, which
is a good thing.
CLARIDA: It is.
Now, speaking of inflation, since the Fed
announced in January of 2012 that it was pursuing
a formal inflation target, inflation has undershot
that target for four years and will likely
to undershoot this year.
So how would the Fed react to a modest overshoot
of inflation relative to target.
Core CPI, for example, is already above 2
(percent).
Would it welcome that?
WILLIAMS: Yeah, this is probably-when you
say, how will the Fed react-is probably the
time when I should put in my normal disclaimer
that my remarks reflect my own views and not
necessarily anyone else.
OK.
CLARIDA: Sure.
WILLIAMS: So you know, I think that-you know,
you're right.
This has been an undershoot for several years.
There is a-there were some signs that inflation
expectations have come down a bit.
And that's somewhat worrying to me, because,
you know, having well-anchored inflation expectations,
people having confidence that the Fed will
achieve its goals is very important.
So my view-my own forecast, my own view of
appropriate policy is we'll see inflation
move back to 2 percent, not overshoot by much,
by definitely get to 2 percent.
If it overshot 2 (percent) by a few tenths
for a while, that wouldn't be a big problem
I think, you know, because, you know, we want
inflation to be an average, 2 percent, sometimes
a little bit above sometimes a little bit
below.
I wouldn't want us to purposefully overshoot
inflation-the 2 percent goal by a lot and
for an extended period, and here's why.
If we overshoot inflation, inflation moved
to 2 1/2 or 3 percent, say, well, then we
would have to bring inflation back down and
we would have to tighten policy and slow the
economy a lot.
So I think that there are some risks.
There are always risks to overshooting your
target and risks to, you know, having to undo
that.
So, you know, my, you know, kind of perfect
landing for the economy would really have
inflation moving, you know, basically back
to 2 percent.
And then from that point, you know, it sometimes
would be a little above, sometimes a little
bit below, but averaging 2 (percent).
CLARIDA: Mmm hmm.
Now, on that point, we were chatting before
onstage that you attended a conference honoring
Mike Woodford, one of the, you know, great
thinkers of monetary economics.
And of course, Mike's theoretical work has
pointed to the benefits of a version of inflation
targeting, price level targeting, which case
if the Fed were price level targeting it would
be aiming to overshoot now.
WILLIAMS: Right.
CLARIDA: The Fed's thinking on price level
targeting?
WILLIAMS: So, this is, I think, a pretty important
issue not just for the U.S. by for other countries.
I mean, the U.S. and most-as you know-most
advanced economies, and many emerging market
economies and central banks have decided to
go some kind of version of inflation targeting,
where you basically say you want inflation
to be 2 percent and if you're above you try
to bring it down to 2 (percent).
If you're below, try to move it back to 2
(percent).
And that's worked amazingly well across dozens
of countries over the last several decades.
So it's been a big success.
Price level targeting basically says, you
know, I want the price level to grow, say
at 2 percent, but any undershoots or overshoots
are made up later.
So you have this built-in memory that says
if you had low inflation for a few years,
you're going to have high inflation for the
next few years to compensation for that.
Now, that's not the strategy we're doing.
We're doing inflation targeting.
I think it's really important for the Fed,
where we are, close to our goals, is to stay-not
change, you know, horses in the middle of
the river, get our 2 percent goal, reach that
and kind of focus on that.
I do think that based on the work that Mike
Woodford and many others have done, and given
the challenges that we've seen central banks
facing around the globe with achieving 2 percent-I
mean, basically very few advanced economies
today have reached their goals; many have
been below for several years-that economists
and policymakers around the world, we think
the strategy of inflation targeting, and think
hard about whether they should-we should be
doing some version of price level targeting.
I think there is advantages in terms of situations
like the one we've been in the last few years.
But I think that that's kind of a research
project that should be done for several years.
And right now, in my view, is we should finish
that job that we set out.
But I do think it's an important issue for
economists to be considering.
CLARIDA: OK.
I think we've all noticed, those of us who
follow the Fed, that this Fed has been emphasizing
global developments as much or more than other
Feds.
And personally, I applaud the Fed for that.
But does it complicate communications, since
the Fed's mandate is U.S. inflation and unemployment.
Does it complicate communication to be discussing
global developments?
WILLIAMS: So as I was telling Rich this morning,
the answer is, yes, it does complicate our
communications.
And for the very reason you said.
You know, our goals are domestic inflation,
domestic employment.
That's what-everything that we talk about
at FOMC meetings when we think about the economy
and we do our analysis is focused through
the lens of, well, what does that mean for
employment in the U.S., what's it mean for
U.S. inflation, what's it mean for the outlook.
But in the current situation in the last couple
years, several years in fact, global developments
have been a big driver of what's happened
with U.S. inflation and with U.S. growth.
I mentioned already the strong dollar and
the decline in oil prices.
Well, those have had, you know, enormous impacts
on the U.S. economy and have been important
drivers of U.S. outlook and also risks to
that outlook.
So at the Fed and the FOMC we've been kind
of facing this challenge of how to communicate
that.
We highlight the fact that our goals are domestic,
but these global developments are really important
to understand the outlook for the U.S. economy
and the risks to it.
So I have been a supporter of putting in more
language in our statements and our descriptions
of our policy decisions that reflect global
developments, but it has led to some of these
kind of questions that you brought up, is
are we trying to be the central banker for
the world, are we taking into consideration
what's happening abroad in terms of our decisions.
So it is a nuance issue, but I'm a big believer
in transparency.
If our decisions to, you know, hold off on
raising rates in the past were influenced
because of global developments and how they
impact the U.S. economy, I just personally
think we should explain that as best we can
just keep working on being better at explaining
our logic.
CLARIDA: And just parenthetically, one thing
I think has been useful with the Fed providing
now-essentially the code to run its model
that John and others developed, you know,
many of us have been able to run simulations
on the Fed model for the effect of things
like a 10 percent move in the dollar, or whatever.
So you can actually see essentially the same
analysis that you're looking at as well, which
is that it does have an impact on both inflation
and employment.
There are those who claim that there is a
risk to the Fed in reacting to the dollar,
for example, or global developments in markets,
perhaps overreacting to financial asset prices,
which is a general issue in monetary policy.
What do you think about that?
WILLIAMS: Right.
We'll you've written about this yourself.
(Laughs.)
This is an old issue about how do the-you
know, the Fed obviously or any central bank,
but the Fed clearly has a huge impact on financial
market conditions, not only in the U.S. but
globally.
Obviously, financial market conditions then
impact the U.S. economy.
And you know, sometimes when you're a policymaker
at the Fed you kind of feel like you're living
in a hall of mirrors where, you know, you
can't-you know, how do you-you know, if we
do this then that will happen, then that would
mean we shouldn't do this.
So this is why we have economists.
This is why we have models, is to try to think
about what are the-you know, kind of the endogenous
or reactions in the economy to changing economic
conditions and the outlook versus some kind
of shock or some outside event that then feeds
back, and do our best to analyze, you know,
what are the financial conditions, how they
feed that in-how does that feed into the U.S.
outlook, and then what's the appropriate policy.
You know, that's just part of the world that
we have to operate in.
And you know, I think it's really important
not to overreact to changes in financial conditions.
I always tell people that I don't have a Bloomberg
terminal.
I don't watch Kramer on CNBC.
(Laughter.)
I seriously do not-you know, as a policymaker,
you want to-you know, monetary policy as Milton
Friedman taught us and has been studied for
decades, monetary policy takes a year or two
to have its full effect on the U.S. economy.
We've always got to be looking down the road
and thinking about what's the right decision.
And I really do try to avoid kind of getting
caught up in the day-to-day fluctuations in
markets.
At the same time, you know, being aware of
what's happening in the world.
So it is a challenge, but we try to do the
best we can.
CLARIDA: Yeah.
In addition to your full-time job as the president
of a district bank, you're also continuing
to do research, and in particular research
with Thomas Laubach at the board has been
quite influential, certainly on me and a lot
of others for thinking about this idea of
the time variation and the equilibrium or
neutral real interest rate.
So perhaps you could tell us the current state
of that work and, in particular, as I understand
it, you're extending this to some other major
economies as well.
WILLIAMS: Right.
I mean, this is actually one of those times
where being a researcher at the Fed was a
great opportunity for actually thinking about
issues that other people weren't.
So back in the '90s-late '90s Thomas Laubach
and I were starting to think about, you know,
what's the normal or neutral interest rate.
And it all started with this idea of a Taylor
rule, which is some kind of mathematical equation
that tells, you know, a central bank how to
move interest rates as the economy changes.
And that has this-you know, the Taylor rule
has a notion of a normal or neutral or equilibrium
interest rate.
And so my colleague, Thomas Laubach, and I
have developed a model on that.
And one of the things that, you know, in neutral
interest rates in the past, which tended to
be between 2 percent or 3 percent on a real
basis, inflation-adjusted basis.
So a short-term interest rate of, say, 4 or
5 percent would be normal in the past, in
our estimates.
Then we saw a dramatic change over the last
few decades, but especially since 2007, where
our analysis says that at least currently
the U.S. economy, the neutral interest rate-again,
on a real basis, an inflation-adjusted basis-is
about zero percent, which means that, you
know, a 2 percent short-term interest rate
is a neutral interest rate.
This is a huge decline.
It reflects slower trend growth in the economy.
It reflects other global factors that are
pushing down globally kind of neutral interest
rates.
And there's been a lot of research on this,
a lot of analysis.
But one of the things that we've been working
on now is looking is this just in the U.S.,
is this something particular to the U.S.?
I mean, often Americans and American economists,
because we have all this data, we tend to
focus on our country and kind of ignore other
countries too much.
So we've been looking at Europe, Canada, and
Britain as using our model.
And what we're seeing is a very similar pattern
in all of those countries.
A couple things: One is slower trend growth.
Basically because of demographics in all these
countries is slower population in labor force
growth, but also slower productivity growth.
Similar patterns across all the other advanced
economies.
We're looking at, and in each case, we're
finding this neutral interest rate coming
down significant, and especially in the last
decade, to numbers that were much lower than
we've ever found.
I think this is a-you know, we can-there's
a debate among economists about, you know,
will this revert back to normal eventually?
But it does present a significant challenge
to central banks, because if you're neutral
interest, you know, your normal interest rate
is, say, 2 or 3 percent, that means when the
next recession happens, you know, once we
get out of this-you know, for those countries,
once they get out of it, they're going to
be starting with an interest rate that's like,
you know, 2 or 3 percent.
Typically, in the U.S., when there's a recession,
the Fed cuts interest rates by about 5 percentage
points.
So you know, we hit the zero lower bound this
time in 2008.
Basically, if this kind of research is right,
then countries in the future are going to
be hitting the zero lower bound and basically
finding monetary policy struggling and needing
to go to unconventional policies much more
frequently.
I think it raises a whole bunch of issues
that we need to be thinking more about in
terms of the future.
CLARIDA: John, were talking right before we
came in that one of the things that's noteworthy,
at least to me, about this-about this cycle,
of course the Fed hiked in December, but at
least, in my case, going back to the 1960s,
I think this'll be the first rate hike cycle
for the Fed in which its actually beginning
to hike rates when inflation is below the
desired level.
So typically a rate hike cycle occurs because
the Fed wants to reduce inflation or, as in
'94 and '04, it begins to hike when it wants
to keep inflation at the current level.
So does this present a communications challenge,
hiking when you're also saying we want inflation
to go up?
WILLIAMS: Apparently it does-(laughter)-based
on my email that I get and the bloggers comments
about some of our-some of the things I've
said about the need to raise interest rates
even though inflation is below 2 percent.
So I think-first of all, I think it's actually
a good thing that we're doing this because
of this lag in monetary policy.
Again, it takes a-well, based on research,
it takes about 2 years for monetary policy
to affect inflation rates.
So we really need to be thinking where is
inflation going to be, not in, you know, mid-2016,
but where is it going to be in 2017, 2018?
And you know, as you know, Rich, the history
of the Fed has not always been a good one.
In the past, there's been the stop and go
policies, especially back in the '60s and
'70s, where the Fed did wait around too long,
allowed inflation to get too high, then had
to put on the breaks, cause a recession, and
then take-you know, put the pedal to the metal
again to get the economy going.
We're trying to avoid that on and off kind
of cycle, and just gradually move interest
rates over the next several years back to
normal in anticipation of where the economy
is going to be in the next couple years.
In terms of communication, it definitely does,
you know, raise the question that people say,
what's the rush?
You know, why are you raising rates when inflation
is still about 1 1/2 percent on kind of an
underlying basis?
You know, and my answer is: You know, we were
at zero for seven years.
We've only raised the rate once.
I don't know how the word "rush" fits into
that description of the Fed.
CLARIDA: (Laughs.)
WILLIAMS: But again, I think we're trying
very hard to balance the need to be forward
looking, but also the fact is that this is
a global environment where growth is going
to be slow and there's a lot of disinflationary
pressures globally, even though the U.S. economy
is doing better.
CLARIDA: So the Fed, of course, has a large
balance sheet, about $4.5 trillion, reflecting
the quantitative easing programs.
And at various times in minutes and statements,
the Fed has also-Fed officials have also indicated
a desire to have the balance sheet shrink
over time.
So could you update us on the current state
of play of the Fed's thinking on this, because
it has evolved.
And in particular, when the balance sheet
does begin to shrink, how will that occur?
WILLIAMS: Right.
Well, the balance sheet, you know, started
at about, you know, 850, 900 billion (dollars)
when we started in 2007.
And as you said, we're over $4 trillion now.
And most of that increase is due to the quantitative
easing programs that-QE programs that we've
done, which increased our asset side and obviously
equal increase in the liability side in terms
of reserves and the Federal Reserve system.
So the current thinking is that we're going
to use the Fed funds target, the short-term
interest rate, as our primary policy tool
to adjust to reflect macro circumstances,
and leave our balance sheet at least for the
time being where it is.
And how do we do that?
Well, as our assets basically mature or are
paid off, we're reinvesting the proceeds from
that to keep the quantity of our balance sheet
at the same level.
And we've been doing that for years now, and
we'll continue to do that for the time being,
and basically adjust the interest rate to
changing economic conditions and outlook.
Then, once we get well-away from zero, basically.
Once the normalization is-we've made enough
progress on that, then we're going to allow
the balance sheet-the plan is to allow the
balance sheet to basically organically decline
over time.
And what I mean by organically is that, you
know, we hold Treasury securities, they mature
eventually, when they mature we just won't
reinvest that.
And our mortgage-backed security portfolio,
those mortgages do get paid off, you know,
either through principal payments or people,
you know, paying off their mortgages.
And over many years-well, actually, many,
many years, that side of the balance sheet
will come down.
Now, based on our own projections and, you
know, analysis we do, once we start this process
of allowing the balance sheet to shrink over
time, it would get back to a more normal level
in, you know, about, you know, six or more
years or something.
So it's going to be a very gradual process
of moving that back to whatever the new normal
there is.
Now, I think the point is really about communications
in my view, is that the Fed funds target is
really the active tool that we're using, either
up or down, to respond to changing circumstances.
And the balance sheet is basically just happening
in the background.
Now, the good news for transparency is every
Treasury security, all the securities we owe,
is publicly available on the Fed-New York
Fed's website.
So you know, people can plan ahead.
And I don't think there'll be disruption when
we start that.
So it's really just a matter of having that
happen slowly over time.
Now, the big question, I will tell you, is
what's going to be the new normal for the
balance sheet?
And that's something that we haven't actually
decided.
This is something we are studying.
And the idea is to shrink the balance from
where it is today, but, you know, we'll see
over the next few years, we can think hard
about should the balance sheet shrink all
the way down to where we had just maybe $25
billion of excess reserves, or we want to
take a different stance, and what's the right
amount of excess reserves?
And this is an ongoing research topic.
CLARIDA: Thank you.
One more from me, and then we'll turn it to
the audience.
So be thinking of the questions you'd like
to ask.
One interesting development in the U.S. labor
market is after several years in which labor
force participation was declining, it began
to pick up about a year, year and a half ago,
as some discouraged workers reentered the
labor force.
So, how do you and others think about that
as potentially a positive for the supply side
of the economy and for those individuals getting
back in the labor market?
So how much more potentially do we have to
go on that?
WILLIAMS: Yeah.
Well, that's a big question.
I mean, you know, we don't know.
We're not that good at predicting labor force
participation.
I think that we-during the recession, we saw
two big developments.
One was dramatic decline in labor force participation
because of retirement of the baby boomers
and things like that.
So that's kind of the part that we more or
less understand.
The other was a decline that I think was due
to cyclical factors.
It was the worst recession in, you know, 50
years, it lasted a long time, people did drop
out of the labor force who actually do want
to have a job.
So as we've seen the labor market get better
we've been adding, you know, millions of jobs
in the last several years, we are seeing some
people come back into the labor force, and
as we mentioned last year a noticeable pick
up there.
So my own view is that most of the-you know,
where labor force participation is today,
most of that is structural.
Most of that-the declines that we've seen
is due to demographics and things.
But we definitely could see some further increases
in participation as we pull more and more
people into the labor force who had basically
been sidelined during the recession and during
the recovery.
It is a question mark.
It's one of those things that, you know, we
have to continually update our estimates.
One of the things-you know, when you're a
policymaker, you have to basically be (bazy
?). And you're always, you know, reassessing
your assumptions, you're reassessing your
views based on the incoming data.
And if labor force participation does pick
up-continue to pick up, then I, you know,
would probably be more optimistic about how
much further increase we could see.
Right now I feel like we're probably close
to the trend, but I have an open mind on that.
So what's it mean?
Well, what we've seen in the last several
months, even though we've been adding a lot
of jobs, unemployment has not been coming
down.
It means more supply side to the economy.
And so it's a positive development.
When I look at some of the statistics that
they collect, they actually ask a question
in the monthly survey of households, and they
do ask the question: If you're not in the
labor force-meaning you're neither working
nor actively searching for a job-do you want
to work?
And that number of people who want to work
but aren't in the labor force has shrunken
dramatically over the last few years.
So at least from that question, there doesn't
seem to be a lot of people still standing
on the sidelines.
CLARIDA: OK.
So at this point I'd like to invite members
to join in the conversation with their questions,
and reminding this meeting is on the record.
So if you have a question, raise your hand.
A microphone will be brought to you.
Please stand, speak directly into it, your
name and affiliation.
And please limit yourself to one question
and keep it a question.
So let's see.
I see Willem Buiter there, so we'll let Willem
kick it off.
WILLIAMS: Willem, the way to turn a statement
into a question is just to say, don't you
agree, at the end?
(Laughter.)
Q: Right.
Willem Buiter, Citi and Council on Foreign
Relations.
I was somewhat shocked by not surprised to
see-hear no reference to the words "financial
stability" in the entire exchange here.
The Fed has not just a monetary policy dual
mandate-in fact, it's a triple mandate, (model
?) long-term interest rates, but never mind-it
has a financial stability mandate.
And much of the Federal Reserve Act is, in
fact, about this.
Now, we clearly are in the U.S. suffering
from late-cycle syndrome, right?
Non-financial corporate credit, especially
high-yield.
We see CLOs backed by subprime car loans in
large amounts.
We even see, again, CLOs backed by residential
mortgages-never thought I'd see those again-subprime
residential mortgages.
Now, the Fed has not countercyclical macroprudential
instruments.
Is there a case for raising the policy rate
for financial stability reasons, even when
it's not warranted for dual-mandate reasons?
Do you agree?
(Laughter.)
WILLIAMS: Don't you agree?
(Laughs.)
No, it's a great-it's a great question.
And I agree completely with the premise.
The Federal Reserve was created 103 years
ago for financial stability reasons.
And monetary policy as we're talking about
it is a relatively modern phenomenon.
So the way I view the issue in terms of financial
stability is that, you know, given that we
are close to our dual mandate goals-essentially
at full employment and I believe on the inflation
side we're, you know, not only close but moving
towards it, I do take seriously the notion
that very low interest rates for a very long
period of time does create-as we know from
history and from the study of this topic-does
create a lot of basically reach for yield,
risk-taking channel, and can contribute to
I think investors and, you know, I think other
households and businesses taking on risks
that actually don't make sense in the long
run.
They only make sense in the environment of
very low interest rates.
And so one of the reasons we don't want to
keep interest rates excessively low and just
let's see where this economy takes us, if
you will, is because I believe these risks
will grow over time.
Right now, I don't think we're in a significant
risk of a-in terms of financial stability,
or risks of-systemic risks right now.
But we don't want those to occur either.
So I do agree that one of the arguments of
normalizing monetary policy, given where we
are in our macro goals, is to make sure that
those financial stability risks don't further
increase and become more of an issue.
I don't think we face really a tradeoff right
now, because I think that the macro situation
supports raising interest rates, as well as
the financial stability issues that Willem
raised.
So I don't see this as a tension in terms
of monetary policy.
In terms of macro-prudential tools, I agree
with the point-I made this point in a number
of speeches-everyone loves to say our first
line of defense should be macro-prudential
tools.
Well, in the U.S., unlike some countries,
we don't really have explicitly macro-prudential
tools.
So what we need to do-macro-prudential tools
are things, if you think about it, in other
countries where the government will just say
the loan-to-value ratio on mortgages, they
basically lower the level on what's allowed
on new mortgages from, say, you know, 80 percent
to 60 percent, that just is required throughout
the country.
Well, we don't have those kind of tools.
But we do have some tools that have a macro-prudential
kind of use.
And I specifically refer to the Fed's stress
tests, or CCAR process, where basically if
we're worried about significant risks in parts
of the financial system, we have, and we can
build those into our stress test to make sure
our largest banks can withstand a major decline
in asset values or other events in those areas
of the economy.
So I think we do have some tools that we can
bring a macro-prudential perspective or framework
to.
But I do think this is something that-you
know, whenever I hear someone hear, well,
macroprudential's our first line of defense.
In the U.S. it's really micro-prudential,
which means strong regulation and supervision
of the financial institutions, plus some of
these other tools where you can bring more
of what we call macropru perspective.
CLARIDA: Next question, please.
Right there in the blue jacket, yes.
Q: Rollie Flynn, Singa Consulting and Georgetown
University.
We all heard and read about the New York Fed,
the cyber-hacking.
Could you comment on what you and San Francisco
are doing to bolster your cyber defenses,
both technically and in terms of your management
structure?
WILLIAMS: Sure.
And you know, this issue of cybersecurity
is obviously incredibly important, not only
for, you know, for banks, for businesses,
for all of us, but at the Fed we take it very,
very seriously.
The Fed does operate the largest payments
systems in the U.S. economy, whether it's
Fedwire, whether it's check or ACH.
So we do enormous investment in terms of making
sure that our systems are safe and cannot-are
bulletproof, as well as we can.
I think a couple things that means is not
only investing in, you know, hardware and
software and personnel, but also having pretty-very
stringent programs around employees, insider
threats, thinking hard about, you know, what
all those risks are now how those are changing
all the time.
So this is a big area for us.
But it's also for our own bank and for our
own system.
And obviously when we think of the Federal
Reserve System, there's 12 Federal Reserve
Banks, there's the Board of Governors.
All of us are working together on all these
cybersecurity risks to the system, not individually.
And San Francisco doesn't have its own cybersecurity
program.
It's a Federal Reserve program.
But then we're working hard with the banks
that we regulate and supervise to make sure
that they are putting in place stronger cybersecurity
defenses, being much more proactive, much
more, you know, modern in their thinking and
their investments there.
So when a lot of people ask the question of,
you know, we're seeing a lot of-the smallest
community banks either disappear or merge,
you know, why is that?
You know, I actually think cybersecurity is
one of the biggest challenges for the smallest
institutions because it's just a fixed-it's
a fixed cost of running a business today.
The last thing that I think we really need
to do is to see banks and financial institutions
definitely working better together about this,
because there's a competitive advantage if
you can say we're better at cybersecurity
than my competitor you should do business
with us.
And that's true.
But we also want to make sure that we're sharing
information across institutions and working
together.
In terms of-you know, I think the biggest
challenge for us is this is a threat that
is becoming more and more sophisticated, with
a lot of money behind it, and obviously at
times foreign governments.
So this is not, you know, the kid in Berkeley
living in his parents' garage anymore.
(Laughter.)
We are way, way beyond that.
And we understand that.
And in terms of our own policies we've instituted
at our own-at the Fed, but obviously at the
San Francisco Fed too-we instituted a number
of programs that basically restrict us significantly
in terms of, you know, background-we do background
checks, we do a lot more work on basically
making sure that access to the payment system,
to what we call the backbone of the Fed, is
very tightly controlled.
And one of the key advantages of that, apparently,
is that I still use a BlackBerry.
(Laughter.)
CLARIDA: Right there in the front table.
Q: Good morning.
My name is Nili Gilbert.
I'm a co-founder of Matarian Capital.
Thank you.
Thanks to you both for being with us here
today.
Recently at a speech in Sacramento you contrasted
the productivity gains that saw after the
tech boom in the '90s with the lack of productivity
gains that we've seen in the context of current
technological innovation.
And you observed that perhaps this is because
some of the current innovations are more focused
on how we spend our leisure time, whereas
the prior tech boom affected businesses more.
I would observe that some of the current innovations
are also affecting our labor markets, in the
context of companies like Uber, Airbnb, TaskRabbit.
I was wondering if you would be willing to
speak further about how you see innovation
affecting the U.S. economy at this time, and
in particular from your perch in San Francisco,
right next door to Silicon Valley where many
of these companies are housed and many of
these technologies are being used.
Is there anything to be observed in the regional
data that can help us to understand how innovative
technologies are affecting the economy?
WILLIAMS: Sure.
That's a great set of questions that we focus
a lot on in the San Francisco Fed.
So one of the things I said in the speech,
as you correctly pointed out, is that productivity
growth in the U.S. economy is actually back
to its old normal.
This is something that Bob Gordon has written
about in his book and many economists have
studied, including one of my colleagues at
the San Francisco Fed, John Fernald.
And basically, normal productivity growth
in the U.S. is about 1 1/2 percent.
And then we get-during our history we get-in
the U.S. and other countries there's these
periods of surges in productivity growth often
associated with a whole set of fundamental
breakthroughs in technology, whether it's
electrification, whether it's internal combustion
engine, or things like that.
And they all come together, and they basically
transform what we make in our economy and
how we make it.
And we had a mini-boom in the '90s around
high-tech, especially around basically computers,
the Internet, and all of that, and it lasted
for about 10 years.
It was the smallest productivity boom-a small
productivity boom compared to the others.
And the point I made about this one is we're
not seeing it in the productivity data.
So if you live in the-you know, by the way,
when you live in-if you're in San Francisco,
you're not in Silicon Valley, but everybody
who works in Silicon Valley lives in San Francisco
now.
So you-basically, they're creating all the
traffic and everything.
(Laughter.)
So you feel like you're in Silicon Valley.
So what we're seeing is a couple things.
I think-you know, why we're not seeing a big
productivity boom?
One is, is that some of it's just-is really
that it's about leisure time.
It's about sitting on your phone if you're
on the train or the bus or, you know, at home,
and you're, you know, seeing all the amazing
things that cats can do which you never knew
before.
(Laughter.)
OK, so that's great.
I'm not against it.
I love cats.
I say this and people say, you don't like
cats.
No, love cats.
But that's not really GDP.
It doesn't show up as GDP.
(Laughter.)
And in fact, it could be negative for productivity
when you're doing it in your workplace.
(Laughter.)
So that doesn't show up in GDP.
Maybe it shows up in utility.
Maybe it makes us happier and stuff, but happiness
isn't what we're measuring when we measure
output per worker in the business sector.
The other thing is we don't produce computers
in the U.S. very much anymore.
Back in the '90s, we were actually building
the computers.
The chips were built-you know, made by Intel
or other companies.
Computers were often assembled here.
But a lot of this was actually investment
in the United States, in very high productivity
jobs in the United States in the hardware
industry.
Well, the hardware industry has mostly moved
out of the U.S., has moved to Asia, and now
a lot of the innovation is really in software.
And that just doesn't affect productivity
in the same way that all of those jobs-factory
jobs that we saw in the '90s.
Now, in terms of-you know, if you're in Silicon
Valley they say, no, John, you don't understand;
we're mismeasuring.
It's the accountants that are wrong.
It's the-you know, it's the economists.
It's the government, you know, statisticians.
But again, my colleague John Fernald just
did a really good Brookings paper in-a couple
of papers now on this.
And, you know, if you look at the productivity
slowdown, no matter how you slice and dice
it, or how you try to, you know, get all the
gig economy and Google and Facebook and all
these things measured as best as you can,
it still does-it doesn't really change the
story.
The productivity slowdown is real.
Whatever we've seen in the last 10 years is
likely to be what we'll see in the next 10
years.
And it's just basically because the newest
technologies haven't fundamentally changed
what we produce and how we produce it in the
U.S. in a way that earlier ones have.
Now, going back to the gig economy, I'm going
to say something else that people in Silicon
Valley just shake their heads and say, you're
an economist, you don't understand.
It's still tiny.
Even in the Bay Area, it's tiny.
You know, companies like Uber and Lyft and
those, I mean, the tax industry is basically
a rounding error to the U.S. GDP; Airbnb,
these things.
I think they're important, and I think they
have important issues about what employees
are, issues about full-time/part-time employment
and things like that, a lot of issues that
I think our legal system or kind of regulations
need to evolve to fully incorporate.
But in terms of the economy, it's still a
pretty small part of the economy.
So what are-what is the U.S. economy today?
I think a lot of people, you know, I think
are thinking about kind where we are in 2016.
It's not only a service-sector economy, it
is a primarily service economy.
So what are services?
If you look at the national income accounts,
it's health care, it's education.
It's also housing, but you know, so it's just
abstract from that.
But where the U.S. economy, you know, creates
the jobs?
Over 90 percent of the jobs created in the
U.S. are in services last year.
Where is our GDP growth?
It's in services.
Manufacturing is a very small part of our
employment.
It's still a part of the GDP.
And so when you think about-whenever you think
about these changes that are happening, you
just got to go back to say how does this fundamentally
change the delivery of health care?
How does it fundamentally change education?
And how does it fundamentally change what
we produce in our economy?
So these are great open questions.
But right now, you know, we're studying them
actively.
I think there are a lot of regulatory/legal
issues that need to be thought about.
But in terms of the macroeconomy, it's just
not having the impact that I think a lot of
people would have expected.
By the way, even if you try to measure this
utility thing, some people have studied how
many hours people spend on their iPhones and,
you know, Android phones, and for me on my
BlackBerry-but of course, I can't do anything
cool on my BlackBerry-(laughter)-what we're
doing is we're basically not watching-well,
I should say it right-we're watching TV on
our phones now.
So it's basically a movement of advertising
revenue and eyeballs from newspapers, magazines,
and TV-you know, old TV, you know, the boxes
that you watch in your living room-to these
phones.
So it doesn't-again, it's cool, it's interesting,
people love it, but it doesn't create a lot
of GDP and productivity because it's basically
just moving one activity from one device to
another.
And I think I probably out-geeked what I needed
to do on that question.
(Laughter.)
CLARIDA: Right there at the front right table,
yeah.
Q: Thank you.
Stephen Blank.
The views-the rather rosy scenario you described
about our economy couldn't be more different
than the views on the economy expressed by
our emerging political leaders and agreed
on with many of their followers.
What do you think explains this variance?
And, more important, what does it portend
for the relationship between the Fed and the
emerging political leadership we'll see in
the next-in the next years?
WILLIAMS: It's a great question.
And I think it's actually pretty easy to understand,
because at the Fed we're interested in our
dual-mandate goals, again, which is 2 percent
inflation and what we think of as maximum
employment.
And we just take the supply side of the economy,
the structure of the economy, fiscal policy,
we just take that as given.
This is the economy that we're handed, and
how do we best achieve our goal?
So the way I view it is-the Fed, in my perspective-we've
done what we can in order to get the economy,
you know, basically back to full strength
with interest rates.
Interest rates can only do so much, and obviously
they can't solve structural or other problems.
We're doing what we can to get inflation back
to 2 percent.
So what are the issues that really are the
big economic issues in the U.S. economy?
They are much longer-bigger, longer-term issues
about the supply side, if you will, of the
economy: the fact that productivity growth
is only 1 1/2 percent; the fact that trend
GDP growth is 2 percent or even a bit less
than that, which is the lowest we have experienced
in our lifetimes; the fact that, you know,
income inequality is rising, or however you
think about these-or economic mobility seems
to be declining somewhat.
All these issues-the hollowing out of the
middle class-these are all real.
These have been studied.
They have to do with a lot of different dynamics
over the last several decades.
But they're not the things that monetary policy
can or should address.
And so when I sound optimistic-and I hear-you
know, it's a great question, and I hear it
all the time-it's optimistic within the confines
of what can monetary policy do.
Monetary policy can get unemployment down
from 10 percent, which was our peak, down
to 9 (percent), to 8 (percent), to 5 (percent),
or maybe a little bit lower.
But if we try to do more than that, we just
create other problems, whether it's the financial
stability issues that Willem highlighted,
or just creating inflation or other problems.
So I think that this is the disconnect.
I'm optimistic within the context of the hand
that we're dealt with-dealt.
I think the concerns a lot of people raise
is that the hand isn't one that's favorable.
I mean, trend growth is lower than any time
we've seen before, all these other structural
issues.
And again, I can't do anything about that.
So you asked, what's it mean for the Fed?
I think it does, I think, you know, create
a lot of these-this tension about, you know,
the last several years people have been saying
the Fed's the only game in town, right, you
know?
So they're saying, you know, fiscal policy
at times has been at loggerheads, other policies,
you know, or other issues-you know, we've
had government shutdowns and things like that-so
we're counting on the Fed to solve our problems.
And how I'm hearing more and more of these
kind of, you know, claims or, you know, people
raising issues: well, can't the Fed solve
this problem?
I mean, you guys were amazing, you know, low
interest rates, big balance sheet.
You got $4 trillion; can't you use that to
deal with these structural problems?
And we know from history, both in the U.S.
and in other countries, that when you try
to solve structural problems, longer-term
problems, with monetary policy, it leads-you
know, it never ends well.
And I think that that is going to be something
we're going to probably see more pressure
on us to try to use monetary policy to solve
longer-run structural problems, and we just
have to fight that every day.
CLARIDA: Right there.
Mmm hmm, next to Willem.
Q: Mario Platero, Council on Foreign Relations
and Sole 24 Ore.
I just wanted to go back to the short term.
And we have seen some retailers that have
done pretty badly recently, and we have seen
housing in New York that is slowing down.
Apparently, there is not such a great sale
of the new condos that have been built up.
And so the economy seems to be-you know, there
are some issues.
So the question is, how do you put those items
into perspective?
And what kind of bias the slowing of the economy
would have in your, you know, monetary policy
decision-making in the short/medium term?
We know Dudley last week said that, you know,
maybe by June there could be an increase of
rate.
So would the economy intervene, or that is
pretty much a decided factor?
Thank you.
WILLIAMS: So this is-you know, when we say
we're data dependent-and I always say, you
know, monetary policy is data dependent-it
goes right to your question, right?
I mean, wait a minute, what data are you looking
at, which data are decisive in terms of decisions.
And of course, when we say data, there's millions
of data points that we observe and collect
and analyze.
But I, again, go back to what's it-you know,
what's it mean for our goals of maximum employment
and 2 percent inflation, or price stability?
So I look at the data, again, from a two-year
perspective.
I agree with your point that we're seeing
some softening in some parts of the hottest
commercial real estate in the-in the-you know,
the globe, New York and San Francisco.
But remember, this is in the context of, like,
all of my employees would love to see some
declines in rents in San Francisco.
So, you know, it's in the context of a very
hot market.
So we have to read through that data, try
to analyze it best we can.
That Q1 GDP growth, which was very soft, you
know, to what extent does that portend softness
in second quarter?
So far, I think the data are showing that
that was an aberration and anomalous, and
the second quarter's looking better.
But we do want to keep watching that.
We'll get employment data for-you know, for
this month, and we'll get more-you know, more
data on the economy.
We have to take all of it together and try
to get this big picture of what's it tell
us where the economy is going over the next
year or two.
In terms of the retail sales, this is one
of the reasons macroeconomics is not a stagnant
kind of subject or field.
A lot of what we're seeing is this mix between
bricks and mortar, whether you think about
the big department stores like Nordstrom or
Macy's or others, versus online sales.
So we-you know, we have to make sure the-you
know, the data we're looking at is not just
what's happening in one part of retail, but
it capturing the broader trends.
And of course, our statistics have done a-have
to do a good job of keeping up with that.
In terms of where we are in terms of monetary
policy, since you did ask, it's the first
time I've heard the word "June" mentioned
this morning, so, OK, I'll go-I'll bite.
You know, it is data dependent.
And what that means is, you know, Rich asked
me, you know, what kind of rate increases
over the rest of the year.
That's going to-you know, if the data come
in softer than expected, you know, all else
equal, that tells you we'll move a little
bit slower or maybe a little bit later in
terms of the next rate increase.
But, you know, my own view is that, you know,
the data stream we've been getting over the
last several months has been-you know, I always
compare it to what I was forecasting a few
months ago or a few quarters ago.
And my view is, in terms of employment and
inflation, the data-the data we've been getting
in the last few months or quarters is basically
consistent with the forecast I've had.
So, you know, there are some ups and some
downs, you know, and everyone gets caught
up in that labor report or that retail sales
or that, you know, manufacturing report, but
overall I view that the data have been consistent
with, you know, a good 2 percent growth and
steady job gains.
CLARIDA: Right there.
Straight on.
Yes.
Q: My name is Peter Goldmark.
I'm an independent consultant to foundations
in the climate and energy area.
This is a room where a lot of people will
be familiar with Mervyn King's "End of Alchemy."
And I wondered if you would share with us
your reaction to his recommendations to, quote,
"avoid the next financial crisis"-the two-track
system, wide banking, narrow banking, different
reserve policies.
What are your thoughts on that?
I found it very powerful.
WILLIAMS: So, you know, there's-obviously
there was a lot of reassessment/reevaluation
of the appropriate regulatory framework after
the financial crisis-a lot of studies being
done by universities, by academics, and policymakers.
In the U.S., I think that the approach that
has been taken so far has hit the most important
kind of risks to the financial system in terms
of making sure that our biggest banks have
adequate capital liquidity, that we put in
enhanced supervision.
The bigger you are, the more supervision and
regulation you get, and the more demands we
have for you for capital liquidity-basically
putting on, if you will, as an economist,
like, a-if you create a negative externality,
meaning that by being very large you create
a risk of too big to fail, that we put more-basically,
more requirements on you, making that a-making
you make the tradeoff between should we be
big and take on all the extra regulatory requirements,
supervisory requirements, or choose not to
be big.
So I think that the approach we've taken so
far has been the right one in general.
It's very complicated.
It's got-you know, nothing's perfect.
But right now I feel that the-you know, in
terms of the largest banks, in terms of the,
you know, financial system broadly, we're
in a much better place than we were 10 years
ago.
However, I think that the issue that we should
be kind of reassessing or reevaluating over
the next five to 10 years, or thinking about
in terms of the future, the way-getting to
your question, is, what do we do in the U.S.
around the shadow banking system?
Which is now-because we're-gotten more regulation,
more requirements on the regulated depository
institutions, it's just obviously pushed more
and more activity to the non-depository institutions,
or the shadow banking.
And I think that this is the area where I-where
I worry.
As it's grown, it creates a lot of systemic
risk.
Obviously, we saw that in the financial crisis
with, you know, AIG or Bear Stearns or Lehman
or, you know, money market mutual funds.
So, to me, that's the question that we need
to be focused on, is how do we bring a regulatory
framework that isn't focused-isn't designed
based on what your charter is, but basically
is designed more around how do we protect
the financial system as a whole.
So when I look at what Britain has done, for
example, I mean, I think there are advantages
to their approach, and I think there are advantages
of thinking about how do we create, you know,
a system that makes sure that we just haven't
basically protected one-created a Maginot
Line around the banks, but then created an
opportunity and actually pushed more activity
to areas that create more risk.
Right now, I have to admit that, you know,
the Fed, we're just focused on getting the
Dodd-Frank, if you will, regime in place,
getting the last few pieces, which has to
do with living wills and all of that to the
place where, obviously, the regulatory-the
Board of Governors, the FDIC are comfortable
with that.
I think, you know, once we have all of that,
then some of these kind of deeper, longer-term
questions are ones we should be thinking hard
about.
CLARIDA: And the last question will be right
there at the front table.
Q: Good morning.
Bhakti Mirchandani, One Williams Street.
Thanks for a great discussion.
In today's discussion, you mentioned two developments
that may limit the use of tried-and-true monetary
policies in future crises.
One is the change in equilibrium interest
rates to zero percent, and the other one is
the quintupling of the Fed's balance sheet
since 2007.
Given both of these developments, what types
of unconventional monetary policies do you
expect the Fed to consider in the next crisis?
WILLIAMS: Not just crisis, I think just even
in the next recession, I mean, or next situation.
So let me-let me broaden that out a little
bit.
So say that we had a-you know, it was called
a rosy scenario, but say that we get-for whatever
reason, my forecast of 2 percent growth, continuing
improvement in inflation doesn't come true.
What tools do we have today to boost the economy,
to get us back on track?
So I think it's the same toolkit we used from
2009 till today: basically, interest rates
close to zero.
You know, we could lower interest rates back
close to zero or not raise interest rates.
That would be one way to stimulate the economy,
if it was needed.
The other is we could go back to QE.
I don't think we're out of-at all out of ammo
on that.
I personally think that our asset-purchase
programs were successful in lowering long-term
interest rates, increasing-basically improving
financial conditions and boosting the economy.
So we can go back to that.
I also feel the forward guidance that we used
in 2011 to 2012, basically saying we're not
raising rates for the next couple of years,
was a very powerful tool to clarify what the
Fed's thinking was in that kind of circumstance.
We're not in that circumstance now, but at
the time it was-these were powerful tools.
So I think that those are the same toolkit
we can go back to.
We understand them better.
I think we have more confidence in which are
the ones that work better under different
circumstances, and we can go back to those
if those were necessary.
You didn't ask, but I-you know, we're out
of time.
I will say I don't think negative interest
rates is a tool that we would use, except
at the-it would be at the bottom of that list.
I think the tools that we would use in the
future would be very similar to the ones we've
used in the past.
What I do worry about is, when I look around
the globe, it's not the U.S. economy.
I think the U.S. economy's in good shape.
I think we're in a good place.
You look at Japan, you look at Europe, you
look at ECB, Switzerland, Scandinavia, I mean,
all of these countries are facing persistently
low inflation.
It's going to take-you know, they've got-not
only do they have massive QE and they've got
negative interest rates, very negative interest
rates in a few countries, and they're struggling
to get inflation back on track.
So that's where-if you ask me what keeps me
up about thinking about monetary policy, it's
really not the U.S. so much, but thinking
about what's happening there and learning
from what they're doing in terms of the effectiveness
of the tools that they're deploying.
CLARIDA: All right.
And on that note, we will conclude, right
on time.
So thank you all, and have an enjoyable rest
of your day.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
(END)